But I think that what you're saying right now, this, this, this race war that,
that the left is, is fully behind it and really wants to happen.
And all of this idea of race and all this stuff,
you have to understand that these people are freaking out.
They are terrified that black Americans are really starting to see
pass their game. When you look at a millennial like me, um,
I have lived through a little bit of this and,
and I used to be on the left and I've made no bones about that,
but it just gets to the point where you've seen this all before.
Remember all the way back when to like February,
when we were pre pandemic and we were having those democratic debates,
do you remember.
Oh my God, it seems like a million years ago at this point. So.
There was one of the debates when the Democrats were all going on and on Bernie
and Elizabeth and the whole crew about how racist America was. And,
and I tweeted out something to the effect of, I said, you know, I think it's,
it sounds crazy,
but Trump's going to get 30% of the black vote and they know it.
And that's why they're freaking out. Because before the pandemic,
we know that black unemployment was at an all time low.
There was that crazy moment at the state of the union where he actually,
Trump actually says that,
and you watch the members of the congressional black caucus.
Sit there like this as if, as if this is a problem.
I thought that's why they have their caucus because we want people to be
prosperous and all that. Um,
then we have now these months of, of race stuff,
um, what, what do you think is gonna happen?
Which way do you think the black vote is going to break at the end
of all of this?
Well, look, I think that pre pandemic, honestly, things were going so well for,
for everybody. Um, if you would have asked me that question, pre-plant pandemic,
I would have said, Oh yeah, you know, 30, 40%, whatever, you know,
that that was probably a little high even before pre pandemic.
But I think that what you're saying right now, this, this, this race war that,
that the left is, is fully behind it and really wants to happen.
And all of this idea of race and all this stuff,
you have to understand that these people are freaking out.
They are terrified that black Americans are really starting to see
past their game. When you look at a millennial like me, um,
I have lived through a little bit of this and,
and I used to be on the left and I've made no bones about that,
but it just gets to the point where you've seen this all before.
So you've seen this story play out over and over and over again.
So you get to the point where you're like me and your post 30,
and you're just looking at this stuff. And then you start saying, wait a minute.
And you start thinking differently. And then you,
you amass a platform where people actually start listening to your thoughts.
And there are people like me and, and God, there's so many people out there.
There's the, the me and the Candace and Brandon Tatum,
but there's more than I can count right now, which is great,
which is a good thing.
And that week's the left out because they can only
control the,
the black people that they fostered into positions of power and in their sort of
media, uh, control groups, right? So the CNNs and the MSNBC's of the world,
but there's a lot of conversation that is happening with us.
And I will tell you, I'm Dave, my social media,
when all of these riots and all of this stuff started happening exploded.
And when I tell you the following in all platforms is completely exploded and
it tells me that people are hungry for different perspective.
So back to the black vote, I think we're looking at somewhere between,
and to be completely honest and a hundred percent rail.
I think we're looking at somewhere between 12 and 15%.
And even if we get to 12%, that's a 33% jump from,
from 2016. And if you get to 15 and 16%,
that is double all right, what he did. And in 2016,
and Democrats can not win national elections without
upwards of 90% of the African-American vote. They know this,
this is why they did not win in 2016 because black people just stay at home
because they didn't want to vote for Hillary because of a lot of different
reasons. And yet they do the same thing. They tried out a,
another deeply unpopular,
super establishment candidate that's been around for forever and
say that this is going to be our change candidates.
So they make these same mistakes over and over and over again,
the guy who's going to change all of the systemic racism is the guy that was in
the Senate for like 30 years and was vice president for eight years.
This time he's going to do it right. It's incredible. Yeah.
This time is going to do the right. And it's the same guy that didn't want, um,
integration in schools because he said that it would turn schools into a quote
racial jungle. Yes. Joe Biden said that. Look it up.
Yeah. What a, what a weird thing do you,
do you sense the gays are gonna have a similar crack? The gays,
Oh, the gays, the gays, the gays. Um, I,
I try my best with the gays. I honestly really don't know. I, you can.
Okay.
So you can only judge by the following that you get and you can judge by the
DMS and the emails and stuff that I get.
But also I I'm in Florida right now.
The gays are generally generally more conservative leaning.
I think that there is a subset and there always has been of gays and lesbians
that are working and law abiding citizens.
And they look at some of this stuff and it, it just doesn't jive with, you know,
uh, and I hope, and I pray that the gays wake up.
I think that a lot of them privately are not into the cult stuff.
I think that a lot of them privately either don't vote for liberals
or possibly even vote for Republicans, possibly even vote for Trump,
but they would never dare say it because they would never want to be.
Ex-communicated, like I said, it was, which is what happened to you. And I.
W I think we talked about this last time, but I honestly can't remember the,
the closet thing, you know,
coming out as a gay person versus coming out as conservative or on the right.
Or, or basically anything non woke at this point. Um, which,
which was harder for you.
It was. So when you come out as gay nowadays, right. You know, you,
everybody loves it and it's so accepting and, and it's all good. And it's,
whatever coming out is conservative.
It was one of the most disruptive life events I've ever had in my life.
And you're talking about somebody that you're talking to,
somebody that's been to war, right. So coming out as conservative,
literally literally been to war.
So command conservative was such a disruptive life event.
And I talk about this a little bit, um, losing all your friends,
um, having youth, some family members say, what, what are you doing?
People that were at my wedding no longer talk to me.
All right. Um, the, the best man at my wedding, no longer talk to me.
So it's just, it's a very disruptive event.
So if I had to say which one was harder for me,
it was coming out as conservative because you coming out as gay people have just
like, Oh, okay, well, you know, sometimes there's a problem with that. Um,
most times there's not in 2020, but when you come out as a conservative, this,
this stigma that is thrown on your shoulders is that you are,
you are basically Hitler.
You are basically supporting the worst, most racist,
xenophobic, homophobic the, the worst of humanity as,
as I was called on social media. Um,
and so that is very disruptive and you have to have a very strong sense
of self to come out of it. On the other side.
That's why so openly share my story that people get fired from their jobs.
People. I, it was the most heartbreaking thing. Um,
one of my followers on Facebook reached out to me and her two
grown adult children called her a racist Nazi and
completely cut her out of their lives.
And those stories make me so sad if you're looking for more.
Honest and thoughtful conversations about politics, instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.